his elbow has to come in
and then his Center has to come up I got
to do all that but I don't have to be in
a tank and I shouldn't do a 10 con and I
lose all that
okay so I'm here and then I have to
bring his Center up
prior to the throne
can't hand his head down there I have to
bring his Center up okay so I won't be
in the same time there it is
then
a pop and a pop
in this Center
in the center of things
very quickly
get that body lock body lock and then
just quick
unfortunately
oh
okay listen
not like this
that same thing that can launch this
time I'm just gonna pulse it
thank you
again the first thing is the elbow
right there
hmm
so I'll miss him but I you can see it
so my hand is not going to go this way
pull pulsed clear
boom
okay
so
this part is subtle too
I mean seriously yeah
then
this is where you have you have to throw
I'm doing this
[Music]
I'm moving to him
Foods
we pay attention I'm just going to be
here
ready a new technique one two and yeah
so wonderful
okay so where did I when I'm doing
Cookie's Elsa
I'm in here behind me in your body you
see that and not around your body
and I'm not I'm not trying to get your
joints in weird things
it's right from the beginning
same thing here we're not trying to get
your joints in weird things
write it contact
excuse me do you get do you understand
that okay now it doesn't change because
I'm ready to tie no handcuffs I don't go
here I
so as I move her
it's still the same
still listening okay
now I'm going to do a technique
and I would like for you to have the
same feeling
so your grabs and same thing alrighty
you see you get it okay so I'm gonna I
don't want to lose that feeling I don't
want to come off
okay over here by the same feeling good
to do the same thing
there it is okay now watch what happens
as I continue
you feel same thing thank you same thing
same thing
same thing you see
watch
same thing boom
same thing
I'm not gonna go
if you have resend it
okay so I'm doing different moves but
the technique is the same in the center
in the center in the center
oh
so just because I have a strike in there
I can still hit the strike in not this
loose way but
the strikes in her body
do you guys see that okay
um we should go slow though whoa whoa
okay
Chinese
we're gonna take it off this way
boom and we'll discuss this
boom
keep the same Center
movement if I throw you out for you
oh
quality
don't take it off that feeling
there's this girl right there
so press into it
this is so right
gold
okay
let me go around that way
enter hands on the center let go
you see Anderson
is the body
oh
balance
on
body
up
whoa
[Music]
okay
I don't want to show too much of this
because it's kind of dangerous okay but
also Marshall Lee uh your target is the
back of this head on the street
so this is not how you would do it do it
okay but what we are trying to notice
is uh this cultural thing where you go
like this and see it's loose it's all
loose there's no more Center control but
they take their cue and they fall down
what I can demonstrate is that you can
see that I can still move him in
different angles other than your
throwing angle you see you see so I can
move him
and you control him that angle
uh
same thing here both both hands are now
touching him both hands are now touching
you see both hands touching touching his
Center is what I mean okay uh
so if I don't like where that foot is
all right let's just move the foot you
see okay all right I'm fine with that
foot all right so here's this angle you
see this angle this way
so I would
I would you're touching the whole
thing
I just keep that same collection as you
go
do you see
never
letting him
out
that that's not the drill the drill is
in the center stay in the center stay in
the center
that's my brother
cool
contact center
expenditure Center
okay that's our drill try it again
uh because the way you you're doing the
technique okay so uh Center Center
is he like he's the one who let go of me
you see you get it he he let go of me I
did not I did not try to uh put your
grip in I'm not trying to go here
he he let go so I take the next contact
point you get it that that's that's your
adhesion so whoa he let go I'm not doing
it
if he did not let go
then I would use the grip that we're
using do you see the grip right
here's the grip there you go
okay
because sometimes as you as you go to
let go
on you
you don't have the connection right now
you see that
but if if he's the one who lets go then
you would have the connection you go to
the next connection point he did that
you you get that I'm not trying to get
out of this grip
so likewise I keep the same connection
Point why would I why would I let go of
this connection point when I have a
center to get disarmed
I I have his body okay I have his body
moving his body around moving his body
through
feet holds on
and I keep the connections if you let go
I go to the next connection point but
I'll take my connection point away
okay